bright splashes of color thick blasts of
paint a post-world War II art movement
and break from the old order of
traditional painting
its abstract expressionism and 80
artists from around the world are
showing their work at a major London
gallery and they're all women
the same wild splashy spontaneous style
emerged around the globe this style of
work was a direct response to the
politics of the time to the kind of
catastrophes and Trauma of the first
half of the 20th century so I see a lot
of the workers either a celebration of
freedom of expression or
a kind of visceral angry Rebellion
Revolution against what was happening in
their countries
dark Landscapes by Palestinian artist
malahe afnan exploring the post-war
themes of Exile and memory hints of
architecture or maybe motherhood in a
work by Syrian painter Asma fayumi it's
great the women are finally getting the
recognition they deserve but the
majority of artists in the show are dead
they're not around to hear the praise
increasingly that's changing more women
are being showcased during their
lifetimes that's good news for audiences
and also for contemporary women artists
Kate Dowdy is an established
london-based artist whose work is on
show in Spain Greece Singapore and
Kuwait
it's been a long haul juggling family
low pay and the constant drive to make
art the backdrop for many professional
women artists I really hope that young
women artists starting out today will
get that recognition early so that they
can really flourish and grow and and not
have to face all of these obstacles that
us older ones have experienced
with more freedom today it's easy to
forget that mid 20th century women were
limited to what they could pursue
by choosing to be professional artists
they challenged society's expectations
and helped Forge a radical new period in
art Jessica Baldwin Al Jazeera London